I was sent to earth when my planet
Krypton was dying I feel like I've heard
this story before this is my story
he knows what you told him
this is not a job I take lightly I can
do this and I don't want to waste on the
midnight of it today she's so cool do
you maybe have a little crush on
Supergirl you got good taste kid I am
going to write a kick-ass expose on
Supergirl
you're writing it I'm the writer it's
like riding a bike or severe childhood
trauma you never really lose it Lucy
Lane guess you you are there was the
time I would have done anything about
woman but she don't mean you're doing
things that Superman couldn't even do
car ride you leap into the sky headfirst
into danger that you don't seem scared
and father
you may have powers car but they don't
always know who our enemies are
so we need to be prepared to face anyone
it's been a longtime little one at Astra
we have to suffer
I'm just trying to keep you safe of all
the things the S stands for safety is
not one of them
you're a pointless sad had said it don't
talk to me like that
stand down
you
hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my Supergirl trailer video they just
they have like a throw forward to all
the characters are gonna be bringing on
in the next couple of episodes I've
already done an episode 1 review I think
I've actually done 2 reviews the first
one was non spoilery because it was
after the lake but I'll put some links
in the description for that in case you
have no idea what's going on with the
show what they're doing essentially is
they're riffing on the Richard Donner
Superman films the first two Christopher
Reeve films so the tone the humor the
characters like the energy just flows
from that universe we also need to
address the other big green glowing rock
in the room I love that she's actually
wearing this green dress here will this
show have anything to do with any of the
other Warner Brothers DC shows currently
in season one what they're saying is
brought you know probably not like it
needs to be a success all by itself on
CBS once it's proven gets picked up for
season two then I think they'll talk
about some light crossovers the way I'm
thinking about it now is is because the
multiverse is a thing on the flash now
because we have all these different
earths think of Supergirl is happening
on a different earth from the other
shows that's the simplest way to explain
why characters aren't talking about
other big powerful characters like if
Superman existed in the universe that
the flash is taking place in earth 1
right now it would be all Cisco talked
about did you see that freaking badass
Kryptonian alien dude being the [ __ ] out
of that other guy the other week same
goes for Batman multiverse theory of the
DC universe but as you can see in this
trailer really like the characters are
their point of crossover and we have
Supergirl being the [ __ ] at a Red
Tornado in this future episode here he
was created by T omorrow who worked at
STAR Labs so you know already you can
kind of see points of crossover STAR
Labs is so much fun there's so many
crazy scientists that have worked at
STAR Labs least of which is Arthur Light
I'm gonna be posting a flash video after
this where I'll talk about dr. light
because the dr. light that they're
actually doing on the flash TV show is
the female doctor light but because
Supergirl has the dual identity she has
that Clark Kent thing you know and she
has Kara Danvers who she is during the
day and she has Kara zor-el Supergirl
who she is when she's fighting crime
there'll be two big bads the first of
which and I'm just getting into spoilers
from episode 1 so just careful if you
haven't seen it yet okay here we go
the alien big bat is going to be her
aunt Alaura who's her mother's twin
sister so the way the way they're doing
that is
someone from her family is finding her
that reminds her of her mother you think
you can kind of see the drama there that
in the Phantom Zone which is where a lot
of the alien threats are gonna be coming
from but then you have human threats
Maxwell Lord is going to be the human
big bat although technically he's a
metahuman because he's super powerful we
didn't meet him in episode 1 we'll
probably meet him pretty quickly though
they tend to introduce the biggest
characters in the first couple of
episodes and this will be like a 2122
episode run probably I don't know what
the exact episode counts gonna be in
season 1 but the next big character we
see here is Lucy Lane aka superwoman
played by Jenna Dewan Tatum
that's Channing Tatum's wife what I
think is gonna end up happening with her
character is it's gonna be like a lot of
characters that bring on the flash so
Lucy Lane just gonna be like regular
Lucy Lane she's not gonna get
superpowers anytime soon it's just a fun
Easter Egg for the comics that she
became superwoman at a certain point but
slowly and slowly they're gonna build
this out with Superman and superwoman
characters from the comics and they do
get to use a lot of Superman characters
most of supergirls biggest villains are
Superman villains too so of course the
TV show is gonna get to do a lot of that
the really big strike in supergirls
favor is that because it's on CBS it
also has big Network money so they can
they can do a lot crazier stuff on
screen but because the series has been
in production for a little while they've
also started to announce future
characters that we won't see for several
episodes they just cast an official
Toyman even though this character
supergirls friend and middlee part of
her inner circle is Winslow Schott his
father Winslow Schott's senior will be
the actual Toyman so it sounds like at
some point in the series they might give
him a villain arc and he'll turn into
Toyman to take the mantle from his
father that's always the fun promise of
shows they get like three or four
seasons friends can become enemies
especially if they were villains in the
comics
killer frost is the best example that
right now danielle Panabaker awesome on
the flash is caitlin snow but she is
gonna be so much fun when she turns into
killer frost that's actually kind of a
fun way to think about Supergirl and
imagine the flash like the energy of the
flash if it were told from one of the
female characters perspectives if it was
a show about killer frost like I mean
the flash is told from Barry's
perspective because he's the main
character and the funny thing is is that
Supergirl and Barry have relatively
similar person
they're both total geeks complete
spazzes so think about how the flash
season one change from episode 1 to
episode 23 I really feel like the second
half of that season was amazing like
episode 9 that mid-season finale of the
flash last year was one of the best
episodes of TV ever and then think about
how awesome it's gotten this season so
essentially the same people are making
Supergirl so think about how much more
awesome it's going to get as they go
along so you should definitely add
Supergirl to your TV rotation like your
DC TV rotation regardless of which show
you watch first like in airs the same
time Gotham airs on Monday nights so
whether you watch one or the other first
what's gonna happen is as my videos for
Supergirl probably won't post till like
Thursdays so you still have plenty of
time to catch up on it before I post my
video and what I'm gonna do is I'll
probably do like a trailer video for the
next episode and discuss spoilers from
the previous episode so see how that
works and then after a couple episodes I
can always course-correct if I think
there's a better way to do it but you
guys let me know in the comments like
what do you want to see Supergirl do in
season one I'm really curious to see
what they do with the hank henshaw
character just because harrison wells
was so much fun on the flash but he
turned out to be an evil character in
hank henshaw is cyborg superman in the
comics so i feel like they just have to
do something with that at a certain
point but it's gonna be a lot of fun and
like I said just to kind of prime
yourself if you haven't watched them in
a while re-watch the first two
Christopher Reeve Superman films and a
big shout out to this week's reverse
flash ring giveaway winner
congratulations to the Matt D just
private message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact info
normally the reverse flash ring giveaway
will just be discussed in the flash and
arrow videos but if I know my schedule
has changed I'll let you guys know if
I'm gonna announce winners or do
anything related to that in my Supergirl
videos mostly you guys have probably
figured out that I do like schedule
updates at the end of videos so like as
long as you pay attention to like what
I'm talking about when videos are coming
at the end of each video then you have a
pretty good idea of like the next couple
of videos that I'm working on so like
next for instance I'll be doing a flash
and arrow trailer I'll probably do two
separate videos just because the
Constantine stuff on arrow is like a
whole big different thing so get hype
for that get hype for Supergirl beating
the [ __ ] out of a lot of people that's
gonna be so much fun so while you guys
wait for that stuff to post you can
click here for my arrow episode from
last night and you can
click here for my Supergirl playlist
with all the videos have done for that
thank you so much watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight
you